a Lifeline now damaged the orantas river
has long provided water to Syria's
Northwestern Plains
but since the devastating earthquakes
that hit Southern turkey and Northern
Syria in February the Region's geography
has changed
a 56 kilometer stretch that runs through
areas controlled by the opposition has
been affected Rising water levels and
cracks and fissures in the ground have
damaged Farmland
we haven't heard a lot of losses we lost
a lot of our crops we couldn't look
after them because we couldn't reach
them large cracks means we can't use
heavy machinery and any repairs cost too
much and we can't afford it
suffered through 12 years of war and
most depend on the land to survive
crops along the banks of the river were
submerged after the Quakes and deep
craters some of them six meters wide
affected their roots
we can't work on our land any longer and
this is our livelihood we used to grow
all kinds of fruit here three quarters
of the crops are gone
and I'm not the only one my neighbors
also can't use their land without help
we won't be able to work again
irrigation systems also need to be
repaired because of the altered course
of the river but resources are limited
authorities say there is only so much
they can do to support the farmers
about 2 200 hectares of land has been
affected volcanic sand came through the
surface through large cracks making the
soil unusable for crops
many of the people who live in
Northwestern Syria were displaced by the
war they have already lost nearly
everything now they say they have
nothing left